as we've been talking about all morning
thursday will mark one year since the
attack on the u.s capitol pro-trump
protesters on that day stormed the
capitol building leaving more than 150
law enforcement officers injured in that
attack then president donald trump was
accused of inciting an insurrection and
was impeached impeached for a second
time in the aftermath the impeachment
vote that followed was the most
bipartisan in modern times 57 senators
in all voted to convict mr trump in the
impeachment trial in the senate 50
democrats and seven republicans but that
total of course did fall short of the 67
needed for a conviction
democratic congressman jamie raskin was
the lead impeachment manager he writes
about the experience which came at an
incredibly difficult time in a very
personal new book it's called
unthinkable trauma truth and the trials
of american democracy and congressman
raskin joins us now congressman thank
you for being here
when we say a difficult time in your
family's life we're talking about the
twin tragedy not the political tragedy
but the personal tragedy your 25 year
old son tommy who you call pure love
pure magic in this book lost a battle
with depression on new year's eve
last
you found him it's one year later how's
your family doing
um well it's a continuing struggle to
reconcile ourselves to the new reality
but we're able to talk about tommy
without drowning in grief and agony
before it was very difficult even to
talk about him and so now we can talk
about him and i hope that
my book celebrates him and his life
which was extraordinary although
obviously way way too short yeah
go ahead no i know we both want this
question because we think it's so yeah
we were both talking about it uh during
the break number one i love the title
the book unthinkable because it is what
it is on many different levels
unthinkable about his death unthinkable
about what happened on january 6th but
what struck me in the book is when you
talked about the word suicide you said
it is not a bad word you don't blame
yourself for not saying how are you
doing how are you feeling because you
did say that to tommy he was living with
you at the time yeah he was living with
you but what you didn't ask him was are
you having suicidal thoughts and that
that scared me a little bit because you
think how can you ask someone that
doesn't it plant a seed and it's such an
uncomfortable question to ask you say it
needs to be asked very directly
well
tommy was adamant for the idea that
there's no such thing as a bad word
which is something he agreed with my my
dad about his grandfather
um
but
so so i take off on that idea and i say
suicide's not a bad word it's a bad idea
it's very difficult to utter that word
it's very difficult to reconcile
ourselves to
uh what happened but we need to talk
about it just like i think in the
political analogy here in the rest of my
book we need to talk about fascism and
what fascism is it's also considered
impolite to raise that word but jamie
why is it important to ask that question
so directly well
um
you know
tommy was a young man of extraordinary
promise and passion
uh he wrote plays he wrote poems he was
in his second year at harvard law school
he had everything going for him
but he was um afflicted by a disease
called depression which tens of millions
of americans suffer from
um
and
i don't i can't say that i know that it
would make any difference but
i was with tommy on the last night and i
asked him how he was doing and what was
going on with him and his girlfriend and
everything but i never said
are you
are you thinking about suicide are you
having suicidal ideation
and you know
i think that most parents probably don't
do that because we don't want to plant
the suggestion you don't want that word
hovering out there in mid-air
like that
but
i have
you know cross-examined myself about it
and i feel like
not talking to someone who's depressed
about suicide is like not talking to a
teenager about sex
you know you might think you're
suppressing something yeah but it's
going to be a reality regardless so we
got to talk about suicide just like we
got to talk about violent
authoritarianism in america so let's
let's talk about let's talk about
january 6 because you you laid tommy to
rest on the fifth you get a standing
ovation from your colleagues uh in
congress on the sixth and then the
events of that day unfold we know them
well by now you're investigating what we
don't know about january 6th my daughter
tabitha was with me on january 6 and our
son-in-law married to our other daughter
hank he was there too hiding under a
desk there were only a few kids there on
that day because of covid19
most families weren't there but you know
i had gotten special permission to bring
them in because of the what was going on
congressman just in this short
conversation you've used the word
fascism and authoritarianism
that's where you believe the country may
be going well i think we saw
a fantastic episode an explosion of
violent authoritarianism on january the
6th we've got to tell the truth about
that and we have to have a reckoning
with the reality of what happened and
the way i see it today is that there
were three rings of activity and one was
a mass demonstration called by then
president trump for a wild protest that
became a riot the second ring of
activity closer into the middle was a
violent insurrection called by groups
like the oath keepers the three
percenters the proud boys the aryan
nations the militia groups right
networks but the scariest ring was the
very inner ring the ring of the coup and
it's a strange word to use in american
political parlance because we don't have
a lot of experience with coups in
american history and we think of a coup
as something against a president but
this was a coup waged by a president
against a vice president and against the
congress in order to overthrow the 2020
presidential election and to seize the
presidency for a second term before
joining the committee you were one of
the most well-versed on what happened
is there any new information that you
learned that surprised you oh well
what's going to happen this year with
our hearings and with our report is
we're going to
lay out as best as we can
the complete story of everything that
happened in all of these different rings
of activity and what are some of those
details well
the role that social media played in the
propagandizing of the public and the
spreading of lies the role that violent
insurrectionist groups played in this
event in the coordination among them and
then how those activities were
coordinated with the very inside of the
action as president trump tried to
maintain his hold on so let's talk about
former president trump because he looms
over all of this there's a question of
whether he'll run in 2024. uh liz cheney
uh said on sunday that he was watching
the riot on television it was well
televised uh and did not immediately
step in to cool things off and then his
daughter ivanka came in twice she says
she has first-hand knowledge and said
dad you have got to do something yeah
yeah so it all leads to the question are
you seeing evidence i know you follow
the facts that could put the president
in a criminally liable situation well
let's start with this is there anybody
in this room or anybody in america who
would not come forward and want to
testify if people thought that you were
involved in inciting and organizing a
coup against the us government everybody
would come forward and say i would have
nothing to do with that i would never do
that let me tell you what happened
instead we have this 187 minute period
that congresswoman cheney has talked
about where donald trump's actions are a
mystery and
the overwhelming number of people that
we want to testify have come in and
given us evidence but the closer you get
to donald trump the more we're getting
resistance from a handful of people like
marco meadows like steve bannon are you
hopeful jamie about where this country's
going
it's very frightening yes
we are the world's greatest multi-racial
multi-ethnic multicultural
constitutional democracy that's who we
are for real
and we're also divided yeah but we were
not always that like the multis have
been we've made good on our founding
promises more lately than we did in the
past the greatness of the trouble well
but look the greatness of america is
that we have always been willing to
struggle to become lincoln's ideal of
government of the people by the people
for the people we've been willing to go
through that that's what makes us great
not that we were founded perfectly
because we weren't right the values were
magnificent and amazing that jefferson
put in the declaration but a lot of them
were honored in the breach from the
beginning but we've struggled to become
that democracy we've got to keep
struggling for it and not lapse into the
kind of authoritarianism we see in
russia with putin or hungary with oraban
or with the chinese communist party all
of the people that donald trump loves
this is america so this is the year
we've got to take it all back and
reclaim the country for the values of
democracy that prior generations have
fought for here's to 2022.
happy new year happy new year
congressman raskin a law professor by
trade as we can see uh also also a a
unfortunately full of wisdom on a
difficult subject the subject of grief
and i think people should pick this book
up not only for what you have to say
about the trials of democracy but for
what you have to say coming out of your
family tragedy i do too tony i think it
will help many i think it will help many
yeah well i appreciate that and my son
tommy was a great lover of democracy and
the law and so i try to do honor to him
in this book which is a labor of love
for him thank you thank you congressman
raskin the book is unthinkable and it
goes on sale tomorrow if you or someone
you know is experiencing a mental health
crisis call the national suicide
prevention lifeline at
1-800-273-8255 or text hello to
741-741 and don't be afraid to use the
word in your own house suicide